[Music]
I've never seen the likes of which a
drama has has totally destroyed and
burned a man alive a hundred and three
thousand loss and one day I've never
seen anything like it and we may never
see anything of the likes of which again
James Charles is in a career crisis
right now and the controversy
surrounding him shows no signs of
slowing down
there's so much going on with James
Charles right now that I do not support
that I do not agree with James charge
the biggest oopsie of 2019 this is like
nothing we've ever seen before since
Friday James Charles easily one of the
largest creators on this or many other
platform he has lost almost and by the
time this video goes up may have lost
more than three million subscribers the
makeup of my daughter's in love was she
watches this makeup on tube and now he's
been canceled I've never seen anything
like it and we may never see anything of
the likes of which again
[Music]
welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
experience I want to give my biggest
congratulations possible to James
Charles for being the all time sub lost
champion the coveted title and Crown
goes to James Charles and my condolences
to projared who held it only for like
two minutes
as I was live last week doing this
podcast not only did he lose this hablas
championship but he embarrassed me in
the process okay whatever the drama he's
been through he embarrassed me that's
the worst crime imaginable because
during live during that podcast we're
like wow we will never see the length of
which again literally two minutes later
James Charles had to come dunk on him
and lost like over a million
well over a million in one day so
fantastic beautiful shout out to both of
them this was a really exciting drama
Olympics 2019 that I'm very excited very
happy to bring to you guys today on this
blessed Friday thank you to our sponsors
honey quip and stitch fix and now let us
get into the headline story here James
Charles boy I've been following this one
closer than I should and I've spent so
much time on this that it's embarrassing
and frankly I wish you got the time back
but that's not how time works sadly time
is finite and we as humans can only
spend it you know one time there's no
refund on time time one time at a time
baby so but I have made a purchase with
my time and I bring to you the
explanation of James Charles because
when I first found it most of these
dramas there's a clear cause you know
there's a clear cause and reason and
it's easy to understand Logan Paul
suicide for us he went into suicide
forest and took pictures with a corpse
okay yeah that's awful you know projared
cheetah's wife sent dick pics underage
girls that guy sucks James Charles was
weird because the reaction was so strong
the reaction was insane it was so severe
but it was so hard
understand what he did and so myself and
a lot of other people were just like
what the hell is going on here what am I
missing right so I want to break it down
I want to explain it I want to tell you
what's going on now the first thing I
want to tell you guys is what is T and
why has it spelled I love that
now there's a expression in the beauty
community they say they call drama
spilling tea which is so much better
than drama or exposing or the other
words spilling tea you like it I like it
he was in it she's in it she's a drama
queen baby spilling that tea
I guess because it's like you're sitting
there with a tea cup and it's like I
spilled my tea [ __ ] I'm gonna kill you
because another thing I learned is that
the I thought the commentary community
was bad
these drama communities is cutthroat
these [ __ ] kill these [ __ ] are a
they slay I mean they are crazy these
girls are crazy
I actually think dude when girls fight
it's like nuclear bro that's true you
know like like this true commentaries
like the guys version yeah dudes hustle
but girls [ __ ] skill they are scary
and James Charles he calls his community
sisters hi Chester dude we don't have
somebody that do it so here we go
taught to you by the way since this has
begun Tati is the so-called mentor of
James Charles who was started it was the
one that exposed who spilled the tea
initially she is his self-proclaimed
mentor and also mother she's refers he
says she's a son to me she kept saying
throughout her initial video by sister
she's 37 years old James Charles is 19
so there is kind of a mother maternal
relationship there what makes it all the
more brutal when she
started to [ __ ] bury him and tap
dance on his grave she decided to
compost his body dude I had a wonderful
that make ups by the grave biodegradable
because she buried that mother effer she
gained four million subscribers since
seven days ago when this started and
James has lost three million she went
from like five actually I think must be
more than four because she went from
like five million subs to over ten now
so she took the three with some change
oh yeah she picked up a couple on the
way with interest yeah
James has tumbled severely so what the
hell happened okay so Tati she sells
vitamins she developed some vitamin for
like skin cannon and her hair and nails
and James is a good friends a friend of
hers um and so James goes on his
Instagram and he promotes one of her
competitors it starts with this video
this is what pissed her off this channel
is called uh just for the record tea
spill legend there's like a whole drama
community and they all have tea in the
title tea spilled how is this dramaalert
like as a name because yeah it's more
clever they've thought about it a little
more but when I think of like tea time
or spill the tea I just think of this
Kermit the Frog name you know which I
love by the way it's like this
this is billing the tea so good so
anyway I sisters so she had she makes
she develops vitamins she sells them and
so he walked with a competitor here's
the video that started it all the powder
keg
take him out and get me claimed here
please the seat it's like okay it's I
want to tape the tape you know thing I
notice that all these tea channels use
the Yoshi theme song and one I don't
know how they don't all get claimed and
do how the hell did they all end up
using the yesterday thirties we can bet
you none of them even play sisters
security because it was crazy and
tendo's about to spill the tea on all
this community they claim all the [ __ ]
they actually should listen I'm [ __ ]
it's not that I'm just saying just play
it from here
ela helped him out with security but
they just came out with a brand new
vegan sleep vitamins and first of all
it's Obama but most importantly I've
been dealing with a lot of anxiety
recently and it always comes late at
night when I'm laying in bed thinking
which is not fun or fresh um so I've
been taking these versions of this
before bed and they've been really
really healthy so if you guys want to
check it out you can swipe up okay so he
basically promoted their sleeping
vitamins so they helped him with
security at Coachella for some reason I
guess he wasn't prepared for the madness
that was gonna happen there he shut up
then but then he did um
tag this as ad yeah I don't believe I
don't believe he wasn't saying James
Charles probably makes a lot of money
for one of these spots he says you want
to pay whatever it doesn't matter
she gave him a shout-out whether he was
paid or not doesn't really matter yeah
but sugar bear hair I guess they're
super popular like these little gummy
vitamins that everyone's [ __ ] around
with on Instagram you chew it apparently
make sure hair and nails better it
sounds like snake oil to me probably
just a normal ass vitamin that you can
buy anywhere like a multivitamin that
they rebrand they just branded it really
genius Lee you know it's like a gummy
bear it's got a cool package right but
they charge like and they're like it's a
forty bucks you get one per day yeah you
know I think you have to keep buying it
every month because you're like oh maybe
it is working but just a multivitamin I
think what the [ __ ] do I know anyway
that's it
so she
super upset Yetta Yetta Yetta why are
all these people selling vitamins I
don't know
these there's huge Webster huge
disclaimers on their website and tatties
website it says not evaluated by the FDA
I don't know I don't know what's her
Tottie's credentials to be making
vitamins I don't know anything about her
this is all new that whole industry is
it gripped honestly all those vitamin
things that's why how it's Jones sells
vitamins - yeah like she has a Kiwi of
vitamin it's Kiwi extract I don't know
I'll lead a Kiwi exactly probably
healthier so so much here I don't really
see what's the big deal even if selling
the competitor I mean like it's enough
room and there's enough space in the
world for everybody I mean that was my
initial feeling that big of a deal so uh
well here letting ahead of myself I
don't know why don't I have a link to
her video of her crying on insta time
dude they didn't research because I
write off the way you post this video on
Instagram I feel really lost and I feel
in my community especially like I feel
really lonely and through this whole
journey of you I feel like I have been
someone who's been super supportive to
my friends and it's been really crap to
feel like I'm not you should do things
to get support but like you know let's
just support one another that's how it
should be and you know I just I'm having
one of those days where it's like
smacked in my face of what's what and
having to take a look at things and
realize what they are and not wanting to
realize what they are when you do so
much for people in your life and they
not only don't return the favor
but they just
don't even see you like I'm just so
upset
I feel really used and that's the bad
part of Hollywood welcome to business
[Laughter]
okay so here she's talking this is in
response James yeah promoting the gummy
bear vitamin it seems like I mean I
don't know I'm not in it but it seems
like a lot to again there's enough space
in the whole world for ya also he
promoted their sleeping vitamin he
didn't promote their hair vitamin right
so but she doesn't sell it her beauty
products called halo beauty I believe
but the thing is that to make a video of
you crying like that yeah what what's up
with this photo there's something
there's something there's something
going on here but okay well this is her
website she makes these supplements one
is a beaut F hair skin and nail booster
on the other was heah kiwi skin booster
so it's 30 bucks and forty bucks it's a
month supply you keep buying them right
down here it says these statements have
not been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration our product is not
intended to diagnose treat or cure or
prevent any disease the nutritional
information expressed by hello beauty is
not intended as a substitute for medical
advice if you are pregnant and or what
the hell but I don't know if this is
like a normal thing there you'll find on
anything well yeah and it is clear yeah
any snake oil any even just I think most
multivitamins aren't evaluated like I
think this is pretty standard like
you're going to G&C
like all of those all the [ __ ] they sell
in there is gonna have the same warning
label well regardless we it's just a
vitamin yeah so anyway yeah I don't know
if I should wait for you to keep
presenting what happened
sure let's let's let's keep going you
can jump in so she is upset she goes at
people suspect that it's in response to
him and then he actually I guess
confirming it she said everybody says
what they need to say and use as soon as
they need to use and I've had enough
it's not right so James Charles I guess
having realized that she was talking
about him posted a story I guess she
thought that wasn't juicy enough it was
all in the stories right she wants two
doors yeah the first right at all and
Instagram stories these aren't
impermanent these are not this is like
the least serious way to address
anything because I want the public Paul
apologized to my close friend Tati she
has been like a mother to me since the
first days in this industry and has
given me more love support and resources
and advice than I could ever ask what do
you call when you kill your own child
infant to siyul
infant side and facade this is cheb in
facade this weekend I did an Instagram
story for sleeping vitamin that I've
been taking because the brand help me
with security when the crowd around me
at Coachella became unsafe I did not
accept any money for the post as you
know tatsi has a vitamin brand they take
on a daily basis but in the moment I did
not think about the competition which
was a major oversight I've supported
toddy both online I found like she has
done for me and I am devastated that I
heard someone that I truly love and have
endless respect for seems fine yeah I
saw people were mad that he didn't
mention her company by name I don't know
what people care that much do you not
understand that you're all being grifted
like she's just selling you item ins for
40 bucks you can't be so insecure by
your company alright if the product is
good it will perform you know right and
a little tiny shout-out would be enough
you don't have to like squeeze your
friends for like okay the shower wasn't
it
it's like a jealous girlfriend who like
doesn't let you like talk to other women
ever
so that's kind of the vibe I'm getting
is that I just don't understand why
she's so insecure about her product
essentially yeah like you like you said
either but again I mean everybody has
taught ease back I'm gonna warn you all
right now I am critical of Tati and so
if that's too much for you I think I lay
it out I've got some good compelling
arguments here I would like you to
listen and not abandon ship okay I'm not
a Tati hater I'm just an objective
outside doesn't know anything about
either of these two creators and I'm
giving you my two cents because that's
what I do because this shows called my
two cents isn't it oh my - seventy
thin-client
I'm changing the name okay my two cents
or if I'm not the Pope so yeah yeah
anyway this leads to her explosive video
called bye sister which is a 40 minute
long rant about James Charles where she
goes on well here's her main points I
mean it's a long mother effing video boy
I invested I watched this video 40
minutes long good
oh man it's hard to listen to I'm not
gonna lie apparently she made it also
because someone else kind of publicly I
said I've made that Instagram story
there was another beauty queen friend of
James I guess I don't know who had
called her out being like [ __ ] don't
you cry on don't you go on Instagram
crying [ __ ] and like because they're
all insane cutthroat crazy
they've all got poisoned tip daggers and
so she's like oh I'm not having my name
dragged [ __ ] I made you and I will
destroy you
she's dead in her mind and so she went
off Yas Queen bye sisters so in short
she basically is mad that he promoted
her competitor she thinks he's a douche
she thinks he's immature and he has a
history of pursuing straight men too
aggressively
those were her main grievances but she
goes in pretty deep like she talks about
how she went to dinner with his family
and she was talking about how he was
talking super inappropriately about like
[ __ ] and sexual stuff in front of
his own mom and dad and that they were
uncomfortable but I was like when I
heard that I'm like dude that's a
private moment between his family and
you were there as a guest I don't really
think that that's a fair and also it's
like you're choosing to surround
yourself with his people if you don't
like him why are you hanging out with
him well I see her point is that he got
progressively worse as we came more
famous okay so this is by society star
privately yeah like who I yeah just a
just to you know what he was factual
about this I believe it was her birthday
party so no no that's two separate about
that was those different in yes okay so
her birthday party that was when he was
hitting on the waiter and she had to
apologize to call everyone the next day
and apologize this was a separate event
when she was eating dinner visiting with
his parents she went over to his house
his parents house I met his parents I
didn't use that against him yikes that's
kind of [ __ ] yeah I remember she was
like there's a big deal that she was
going to meet his parents so that that
rubbed me wrong to be honest with you
there was other really well to me it's
like you're 37 and he's 19 he's a kid
who got famous really quickly and super
rich and he's a kid so he's gonna do
stupid [ __ ] and you're 37 and you're
obviously way more mature than him
supposedly it should be so yeah maybe
you shouldn't hang out with him cuz it's
gonna do dumb [ __ ] that you you're like
way past you know right right I mean and
then so that's something really
important to bear in mind is that she's
37 he's just turned 19 and so and they
are always both talking about that he's
a mother she's a child and you know this
so that relationship really for me makes
this even worse for her because if she
really has this maternal instinct for
him it's so [ __ ] up that she like bear
like she her goal is to destroy him
because she airs every grievance
everything
she goes all out and like stuff like
private [ __ ] like meeting his parents
and saying he was inappropriate I mean
there was other stuff I can't work all
that rubbed me wrong but I have first
let me I have let me I have a list here
of stuff i'ma start and from the
beginning it rubbed me wrong and I'll
tell you why she starts by showing
pretty much a compilation of time she
shouted him out and helped him that's
how the video opens I'm gonna play for
you now James is here to do my Bridal
makeup which is what I am wearing right
now Instagram I want to say huge
congratulations to James Charles if you
have not checked his channel out on
YouTube and you want to be inspired he's
a freaking teenager and he's like a
genius with mica James Charles is the
face of their holiday collection I
remember what I wanted to say is that
she goes in her video she's like he's so
immature you know when I met him he was
kind of immature but I was hoping he
would grow up along the way but I can
see he has it so what she's saying is he
was like 17 when I met him and now he's
19 and he hasn't matured yet yeah hello
listen yourself he's a child dude God do
a really cool I do want to say we're not
here to just defend James weed oh I'm
going in yeah we haven't expressed any
opinion about him yet no I'm going in on
everybody is that this is my two cents
and you know how we do I'm just gonna do
the Tati Parker thank you trust me I
don't like either of these people you're
gonna hear about it here on my two cents
to try this palette we are going to be
taking a first look at the new morphe
palette hello I love it sorry James
I'm the friend that's encouraging you
guys to use code James for 10% off of
saving you can use buddies come use you
know James's code I don't worry my
sisters apparel yes okay so she has
compiled every time she's ever helped to
promote him and the presumption
I guess being that he is never
reciprocated or not reciprocated enough
but again the whole kind of premise of
this video for me hinges on the fact
that she's done so many nice things for
him mm-hmm
and she's done it with the expectation
that he would do her favors back and so
that's not really that's not really why
will you do favors right you shouldn't
do favors with the expectation that
they'll one day be returned you're not
the Godfather or I guess in her in her
case she does think of herself as the
godmother I almost felt she cited as an
investment didn't paid off right it's
like this kid is blowing up once he pays
it back to me you know it's gonna be
huge
well she collected her debt she's the
godmother
so that part already rubbed me wrong
it's like okay you're gonna start by
showing me all the nice things you've
ever done for him and then here this
part she goes she says you should never
minimize other people's pain she says Oh
Dan I never got the clip from you
they're all give it to you right now
yeah just put it in discord orbit you
can put it right here where it says
source needed so she contradicts herself
in a really awful way I think she says
let me show you she says you should
never minimize people's pain as she
defends herself by name it really
minimized my feelings it's a horrible
thing to tell a person like hey it's
sunshiny outside don't feel bad about
whatever you're going through and I
always like to tell people pain is pain
and yeah at some point you have to feel
it express it so her point I guess she's
defending herself against that one guy
who's like [ __ ] you shouldn't be making
a video on Instagram crying and she's
saying well pain is pain we all
experience the pain if I'm feeling it
it's real no matter how petty or stupid
you think it is pain
painting you should never minimize
someone else's suffering she says that
in an attempt to defend herself but yet
later in the video when she goes off on
on James
she says this and let me quote you it
seems very good it's just really funny
that we didn't end up collabing until it
was in his favor so he was popping off
online about exposing the beauty
community and doing a docu-series and I
was like know how entitled do you have
to be to think that you have it rough
you are a 19 year old millionaire is
that her minimizing his bank and you
know stress Howard about how unfair your
job is like how are you going to tell
him he doesn't get to wake up and stress
out about unfair his job is when you
start the video by talking about pain is
pain and how dare you minimize my pain I
mean you're literally doing that
she's also pointing out she's saying
you're 19 and a millionaire think about
it for a second that's gotta be really
like that messes with your head that's a
source of great stress we always talk
about like what would we have done if we
got you know our success at 19 and not
like because we were like we got it
maybe at 29 not 19 right so and I have
no idea I would have been cringy
probably oh my goodness I was already
cringy at 19 I didn't need money oh yeah
exacerbate the problem and like people
worshipping me you know what I mean God
if only he had a mother mother figure to
help him sort through his issues you
know she said she kept reaching out to
sort to him but he was unavailable
whatever so I'm gonna [ __ ] fairy and
that's the solution yeah move on with
your life you're 37
someone's got to grow up here to me also
she keeps talking about how like there
you go this is the show business people
are here to get each other
and it's like not necessarily we meet a
lot of people from our industry whatever
it is that are nice that are generous
that will help us so you got to choose
who you surround yourself with if
someone is being
douche or you know you don't like the
vibe you just I just miss my sister
that's true I would say a hundred
percent almost of all the people we've
met have been right I'm a really sweet
charitable yeah once in a while you feel
you meet someone and you feel like you
know what I felt um I hang it out with
that person if you like this person you
use me but are you gonna go and make a
video about that
oh no maybe I will now that I've seen
the numbers she got who can I expose
spill the tea yeah who can I spill the
tea on I was thinking that I was like
damn who can I expose I saw this [ __ ]
exposed pose from one would be pretty
hot I have nothing to expose well make
sure you know I mean I'll make [ __ ] up
about him
what can lie about him for 40 million
views mmm 50 million views that would
backfire on me everyone would abandon me
posts Malone made me drink Bud Lights
even though I was don't like Bud Light I
like but original to be like the lamest
[ __ ] he didn't have but original and I
felt abused yeah I I find that
stereotype about Hollywood's so stupid
like I everyone I know here in LA is
fantastic it is will you make it and
I've gone to these parties right or it's
like these scenes and you see all these
fake lame-ass people yeah and those are
the last people I would want to hang out
with because they're so transparent it's
so obvious when you see girls and tight
dresses just looking for a rich guy to
[ __ ] it's like hello you are blind or
stupid or or in denial
to not see that for what is and you see
the guys cruising around with like Gucci
shirts and Fendi trying to look like
they're actually rich when they're not
or whatever it's like everything is so
transparent and you're not a genius to
spot it right when you see it so I mean
you can surround yourself with whoever
you want yes to be surrounded with if
you go to a party like that and you
choose to go back then okay I guess
you're into it you know what's the
biggest signal that she's a phony look
how many drawers she has wow so true
what bro there's like 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
one two three four there's like five six
rows six times seven
that's like 42 drawers just in sight
then in the absorbable you know it is
how do you even know what's in each
drawer let's say like how would you a
librarian here like you don't need that
many drawers immiscibility on you [ __ ]
people are gonna be so mad but you're
know I'm right
but that thing about saying don't
minimize my pain and then calling saying
that he doesn't have any right to
complain because he's a nitro
millionaire its total BS and anyone
who's watching this knows that I'm right
we have to take a break I guess Dan yeah
we're a minute away from the 30 minute
mark so so we've got much more obviously
I'm only at the tip of the iceberg here
so let's take a break we'll be right
back this is the H Street podcast Ethan
given his two cents let's talk about
something we can all agree on saving
money the reality is if you're not
shopping around you're probably not
saving money so what if there was a way
for somebody to do the shopping around
for you well that's exactly like honey
does what honey does I use a free tool
that you download to your computer's
browser while you shop online honey
scans the internet for coupon codes and
other discounts that are automatically
applied when you're at checkout has a
coupon and it gives you the biggest
savings to your cart at checkout like
magic it works on over 20,000 sites like
Amazon Nordstrom's J snooze as I heard
our designer call it and I can be Best
Buy Target
you called it Jase knows mmm-hmm oh [ __ ]
I yeah I thought you made that up
no that was all you huh damn you oh you
know always comes up with the spiciest
little morsels J snooze instead of
taking my word for it listen to what
actual users have to say about honey
five stars the very first day I use this
I save ten bucks on Amazon and then
another thirty bucks on a subscription
service I couldn't stop using this
service if I tried Thank You h2 h3 and
thank you honey
that is from a real h3h3 person on the
core
store here's another one just saved $81
amazing shout-out to h2 h3 I don't keep
many browsers extensions anymore but
honey is legit
I'll find the best price on stuff you
already buy look there's really no
reason not to use honey it's free to use
easy to install your computer and just
two clicks and don't take it from me
take it from our listeners get honey for
free at join honey calm / h3 that's join
honey Doug um / h3 honey the smart
shopping assistant that saves you time
and money
look you probably care about your mouth
and if you don't I don't know what to
tell you this commercial is not for you
but life isn't for you if you don't care
about your teeth because guess what
you're not gonna get friends you're not
gonna get a date you're probably not
gonna be able to look at yourself in the
mouth because your mouth your teeth is
the most important thing about your face
and about your personal life because
your breath got to smell good your teeth
got a shine you got up B you're
beautiful
most whole self you can imagine and
that's why I love quit because a
toothbrush should be an extension of
your arm too much it should be an
extension of your arm like a samurai
sword
I love quip it's got the softest
Brussels in the game it starts at a
reasonable price of $25 and it's got the
vibrating power of a much more expensive
toothbrush it's a vibrating little tube
okay
this was featured in Time magazine and
goop magazine is one of the best
inventions of all time why because it
vibrates and it tells you it pulsates
when it's time to switch to the other
side to make sure you get that perfect
beautiful dentist recommended brush what
is it like two minutes or something that
every minute tells you to switch sides
it's the saltiest bristles is the
bomb-ass brush in the game it's such a
convenient little package I live and die
by my quick electric toothbrush
I wouldn't use any other toothbrush and
this is a guy coming I'm mouth obsessed
I've searched high and low for the best
toothbrush in the game and qyp has got
you covered and you can also get some
ass to play with the back end of it two
multi-purpose just saying are you I
wouldn't buy a separate one for that
because you don't want to use both your
hands that's that's just my opinion quip
is worth it give it a shot you got
nothing to lose I love quip we've got
over 1 million happy healthy mouths that
also love it too they started just 25
bucks you go to get quip comm /h through
right now you get a first refill pack
free it's this top and a some toothpaste
it's free baby
that's your first refill pack for you at
GE tqu IP comm /h 3 it's time to
transform your mouth
if you're a guy like me and most dudes I
know you don't have time to shop first
of all - you don't like shopping at 3
even when you go job but you don't know
what to buy because let's face it we
don't I don't have taste I don't know
what I'm doing right but you want to
look good you want to look presentable
so here's the solution stitch fixed
citrus is an online personal styling
service that delivers your favorite
clothing brands right to your door to
get started you go to stitch fix calm
slash h3 answer some questions about
your preferred style and your shopping
your personal shopper will ship you a
box of clothes shoes and accessories you
tell them your budget you tell them your
style your taste and everything and
you've got a stylish that goes to the
work picking out the perfect dream
outfit for you but here's where it's
really great is that there's no
commitment required and you only pay for
what you keep shipping exchanges and
returns are always free so essentially
you're turning your home into your own
private super convenient fitting room
plus the $20 styling fee is
automatically applied toward anything
you keep from the box you'll never have
to think about looking good again with
stitch fix so get started today at
stitch fix calm slash h3 to get and get
25% off when you keep everything in your
box that's stitch fix calm slash a
stitch fix calm slash h3
welcome back to my two cents
starring Ethan and yella Klein now I was
listening all my grievances with Tati
and my other one is that she's like
she's got this big important video about
James Charles but she still happens to
squeeze her Lincoln sloppily above the
fault like her beauty like I don't even
remember if it was there in the
beginning if she just put it up after it
started going like mega viral it may
have been there from beginning not that
makes it better but she knew was gonna
get a ton of views halo before and after
this is the hardest video I've ever had
to make halo before and after photos are
here okay Wow that's convincing what is
it is this medicine is it some kind of
trick no it's a vitamin bro before and
after key week now I might be I might be
a cynical [ __ ] I mean I am cynical
[ __ ] that's not but what is in
question is can a multivitamin clear
your skin I don't think so
I don't if it was that easy dermatology
wouldn't exist as a practice you know
what I'm saying I don't know but here
you have it one way or the other you
know get halo calm whatever but she
sloppily you know throws that in there
and she spent a lot of time in this
forty minute video talking about her
product too by the way yeah I was like
whoa she's really plugging it and to me
it seemed like if there is anything
really serious here to talk about it was
all day out of stuff with James kind of
like forcing himself on straight dudes
yeah and I have compiled all of the
evidence of that but basically I think
what she didn't want to do is I think
she was strategic because she just
wanted to open the lid enough to be like
oh she went there yeah but but the
accusations and the evidence is so
circumstantial and unsupported I'm
substantiated that it wouldn't be a good
look for her to go into it but she was
like well at the waiter at the
restaurant of my birthday he was
so inappropriate and he was so hitting
on him and you need to respect straight
guys sexuality and all that okay fine
but that was the most serious claim but
you do me at least well yeah and so and
I agree there's a lot of serious stuff
there that I'm gonna explore thoroughly
that we're gonna get into when I'm done
slamming on this tatty can I say Tata to
Tata Tata sisters and then finally she
starts she goes in coincidentally on
James Charles right as people started
turning on him like he was just started
all the sudden losing subscribers for
three days before she decided want me to
make this video people started getting
angry at him because he was doing like a
$600 VIP fan meetup which is like the
douchiest thing ever obviously and he
also got invited to the Met Gala which I
guess a lot of people were angry about
because they thought he wasn't worthy or
oh right you wrote something here
I first met gala thank you so much for
YouTube for inviting me being invited to
such an important event like the ball is
such an honor and a step forward in the
right direction for influencer
representation and media and I am so
excited to be a catalyst influencer yeah
an influencer representation like he's a
marginalized group well I wonder why
people don't take youtuber serious James
maybe you can tell me more about why
people don't take youtubers seriously by
the way can you tell me more about your
nipple holes here are those nipple holes
ela so not a lion - it is nipples but
they're but but yeah you're right
they're not even qualify you gotta work
on your nipple game Dyke anyway what's I
don't know what's this outfit I don't
know he's like it was my item and
designer everybody was dressed great
yeah the bandana he's like a gay [ __ ] I
mean and so legitimate designer and put
it together Alexander Wang yeah Wang
it's a Wang original Alexander Wang the
bold move on the gay crypt look
what's up homie James Charles be like
what's up homie so it seemed a little
opportunistic to be like oh now is the
perfect time people are ready to slam
she smelled blood in the water and it's
time for the mommy to bury this baby
it's time for mommy to abort this fetus
you know what I'm saying we're in the
ninth term we're in the seventh term and
it's time to abort this fetus yeah this
was a late term abortion for sure on the
part of fatty don't you agree tragic
tragic loss of life so all that being
said James is definitely a douchebag for
all the reasons she pointed out and I'm
not defending him as he looked said
thank you for saying that earlier
because it's from porn for google no did
I hate everybody involved I want to go I
want to go further into why he actually
deserves what was coming to him
and again the most serious claims
against James that I can tell besides
him being a douche or a bad friend or
whatever is that he seems to go after
straight guys aggressive bordering on
predatory apparently and you'll see this
in a lot of his videos he has a fetish
for straight guys which in itself is
weird because that's like the the
undertone under texts of that is is
predatory in itself because you're
you're trying to convince somebody that
by default is not interested in you yeah
it's got don't like like you're not
gonna be able to resist me right kind of
thing she's weird
well it's also kind of rapey to be
honest because I'm not gay and that's
the challenge especially when you add to
the factors the fact that he's famous
and right if he does that to someone
who's fan of his it's extra
you know it's abusive power right
so here I've compiled a bunch of
evidence must go through it is James
Charles a predator let's find out these
are all anecdotes of people again so the
the Valletta the validity has not been
corroborated on most of these but
there's a lot of it so it does paint a
picture all right of a pair of a person
right when I met James Charles two years
ago in a hotel room at playlist he was
not only rude as [ __ ] but he was visibly
trying to get one of his intoxicated
straight friends to cuddle with him to
the point where his friends had to say
James [ __ ] stop nothing has changed
you know and you you almost can get away
with it him because it's like oh I'm
just James Charles I'm just [ __ ]
around but if there's someone coming on
man or women coming on to you that so
hard and aggressive and non-stop to the
point you have to physically push them
off you and say stop you know that's too
much you know now apparently this guy
actually has a picture of him in a hotel
room with him then so it is somewhat
corroborated by evidence but this kind
of stuff isn't that hard to believe
here's more let's continue do you mean
receipts yeah it had what that's the
other thing to say they say with
receipts tea was spilled with receipts
these girls have their own language man
it's fantastic I never talked about it
out of fear of him coming for me but
after the video Tati posted villach it's
finally time for people to know the [ __ ]
he's been done throughout the years
alright thank you
Anthony for coming out very brave there
was that's it that's all I have
there's an ex saga is flirting with
married men let's see here oh so he's
just cold Danning dudes by the way this
is freaking weird
he just DMS dudes on Twitter who
following my guess who are like
attractive straight guys and he goes
he goes oh wow you're so hot and then
the guy responds obviously trying to
make a point my wife is so hot and he
says you could have just accepted the
compliment ha ha ha ha ha ha have a
lovely day it's not like the ultimate
like that's like the cat calling your
I'm just complicating just accept the
compliment yeah kind of douchey right
pretty douchey yeah girly she might just
smile
yeah yeah said I take it more of a
compliment when someone says nice things
about my marriage and my wife but thanks
anyway I guess this guy knew the score
mm-hmm again these are just a lot of
little evidence it gets worse there's
more serious accusations more to fallout
now this one is very serious so this guy
claims he says uh he says that he was
sent unsolicited news when he was 17 by
James Charles there's no evidence other
than this okay so this is very I mean
this is what pro Jarrod got Moy did for
again there's no hard proof but he says
I don't have the screenshots I wish I
did after taking after talking for a
little over a week he sent unsolicited
nudes and asked for them in return I
told him no and he uh nad admittedly
after that it was clear what he wanted
from me and now I have him blocked on
everything that was him having a
conversation one of these tea spill tea
series TV series good hello
that should be my drama name so again
I'm not it's just a lot of this it's
hard to know what's real and what's not
but it paints a picture this guy says he
went to high school with James Charles
and James tells catfish the entire
soccer team in high school pretending to
be a girl so it could get dick pics so
glad to know he's still predatory
apparently he pretended to be a young
girl and was I don't know you gonna have
to read between the lines there this is
all the evidence that I'm just trying to
show you guys everything we've got so
weird so we're done they both like him
and Jared kind of had the same behavior
going on but well
Jared's yeah I don't know it's hard to
tell
Jarrett is way older right I mean
Jared's a old guy and Jared's there's so
much more proof I mean you got the dick
fix
I saw I'd looked even more after we
dinner in that episode and there's
awesomes worse stuff like he had a
secret sex blog called
sin Jared where he had his fans who he
had kind of brought in on this world of
his submitting nudes many of them
underage and he called them his little
sins James Charles swept the whole
projared thing under the rug but Pro
Jared's done I mean that guy's [ __ ]
done done done Tata said Tata Tata said
Tata to projared and Jim strolls so he's
always he's known for always saying [ __ ]
like this attractive straight boys will
be the death of me you know he knows
he's got a problem he's trying to make a
joke about it what can't you just [ __ ]
dudes who want to [ __ ] you you know what
I mean why are you going after straight
guys go after a guy that actually wants
to be what is so exciting to you about
someone that doesn't and so yeah it is
it matter it is totally a power thing
it's like there's a like a sect of porn
that people like [ __ ] where the girl
looks like she hates it that's what this
is you're like manipulating someone into
doing something they don't want to do
mm-hmm
James Charles let's continue it's us
there's someone I'm sorry you guys but I
just got to show you everything there is
so we can draw a real conclusion I mean
I put so much work into this you guys
come on I don't wanna do a story time
video about one
great boy I've had some crazy
experiences with without outing him of
course I'll get whatever keep clicking
next straight boys are the most
confusing and deceiving people you all
stink bro you said they're straight it's
right there man straight boys are
confusing and deceiving no straight boys
they don't want do your dick Danny wants
dick in anyone's mouth period straight
love that for you that's easy either
straight straight he wants a boy who's
fair want that for you that's easy you
told me that you have turned out
straight guys it elaborate on that
because you are famous celebrity and you
do you do live in Hollywood push his
emotions onto me to kind of guilt me
into juror ok it's a running motif even
before all this [ __ ] happened yeah
stop doing that obviously now I don't
know why the F this one is so freakin
blurry when you're drunk the truth dis
oh but this was a part of a larger
conversation this one really rubbed me
wrong he says he's having an argument
with some guy I guess he was friends
with when you're drunk the truth always
comes out so not always but I just want
did to make sure we split on good terms
Charles says James Charles yes always
you're not straight no matter how many
times you tell yourself and I hope you
figure that out sooner rather than later
I know we didn't spoil in good terms
he's trying to convince this guy he's
gay you are not straight no matter how
many times you tell yourself and I hope
you figure that out sooner than later
can you just [ __ ] a street a gay dude no
man
weird
Jeffrey star by the way tweeted this and
erased it there is a reason that Nathan
that's his boyfriend her husband banned
James from ever coming over to our home
again there's a reason why I haven't
seen him since glam life gurus birthday
in February he is a danger to society
everything tat he said is 100% true he's
a danger to society it's pretty rough
what the hell happened at the birthday
party Doug goddamn so clearly anyway
even among his uh his cohorts there's a
I guess they know more than they're
letting on so ultimately it's hard to
say exactly what James has done wrong
but he's clearly have a pattern of
really poor behavior around straight men
and a really weird power trip a really
strange [ __ ] that he better stop and get
examine what he's doing because actually
if this goes unchecked for another like
five or ten years done I mean he's gonna
be he's gonna do some things he's gonna
Bill Cosby some people are Kelly do you
have your passports do you have your
shots girl I wanna go to Jeff free stars
makeup party ooh mmm lift me up girl
here we go why me do you have your
foundation do you have your highlights
boy I want to convince some straight
boys to suck my dick you suck my dick do
you have you Foundation
do you have your mascara girl I wanna go
to Geoffrey Stars house and get banned
yeah thank you guys thank you for
setting me up
ultimately what what what can you say
about James Charles I mean yeah the
guy's a douche he's young he's
successful wildly successful insanely
successful a total douche now what can
we say about Tati on the other hand I
would say she seems like an
opportunistic snake oil salesman that
through her supposed son right under the
bus you know she's full of
contradictions she's full of all this
sweetness and niceness about like she
made a new video called why I did it
another twenty minute wasted life and
she starts crying like I'm not the
victim don't feel bad for me if I could
give back the subscribers I could like
you know shut the [ __ ] up delete the
video then delete the original video if
you feel that bad about it's got 15
million views and Counting such a phony
and she using it to push her product
which is above the fold which is snake
oil to begin with it seems to me that
she's bitter that he became so
successful and catapulted past her and
forgot about her which is rude and
inconsiderate considering you know how
instrumental she was but that can happen
that can happen so does that give you
the right to just stomp on his [ __ ]
face publicly I know I worked out for
you but I just don't think that she's
the same did everyone's making her
that's all I'm saying yeah it doesn't
paint a really great character on both
of them
I agree and you know that's contrary to
the popular opinion because all I see is
outpouring of love
support for Tati and I want to say
hashtag Tata to Tati damn God I went
there time disability [ __ ]
I say unsubscribe to both and subscribe
to my podcast h3 podcast aka my two
cents featuring Ethan illa Klein but
regardless of all of that we have to
appreciate how incredible it is that on
the very same day we were talking about
projared getting but all the times sub
lost on one day that James Krause comes
in two hours later and smashes it on 10
times multiples 1.3 million in one day
incredible incredible stuff only reality
is stranger than fiction by the you know
let me check the social bleeds of pro
Jarrod and then James Charles just for
one last update before we move on so I
mean it's slowed down quite a bit for
for pro Jarrod but per capita if you
look at this like per capita you're
talking about like you know a full-on 20
percent yeah I actually I ran the
numbers last night and he lost 21
roughly 21 percent I mean that is so
that's in one week James was 19 so rare
but pro Jarrod per capita lost more subs
so there you go
so there's no bouncing back for projared
he's like bye-bye don't airs James
Charles on the other hand I was shocked
I was mortified
to find out that his subs are in the
green like strong in the green all of a
sudden on Thursday he was having like a
super strong day and I didn't expect him
to bounce back for a long time so I was
weird
yeah I found it's just so bizarre that
he rebounded so strong just suddenly you
think he might be buying subs cheating
the system I don't know that's a pretty
as a strong claim to make but it is so
suspicious that how easy is it to buy
subscribers yeah it's easiest thing in
the world and what I understand its yeah
that's actually pretty common yeah I
don't know how common it is among what
you I don't think big youtubers buy subs
yeah I don't think that's the thing that
people do may it's easy to tell from the
views if you have a real fan base I mean
the views are not gonna be there it's
fake but I don't know man
well if he bought subs or not is still
pretty shocking to see yeah so there you
have it you can see it dip off like
people sold the stock straight up crash
stock market crash but apparently he's
he'll be back on top and he's gonna pass
he's already ahead of talk to us I hope
he may I was really hoping to make a
video slamming back on Tata but he made
some really shitty apology video that
was so bad and annoying I guess we
should watch that real fast
I think his apology video made
everything worse - because it was just
like him funded YouTube channel okay
he's so [ __ ] annoying in his apology
video 59 years he takes so long he takes
such long pauses James here I'm
travelling abroad but I wanted to sit
down and make a video addressing all
that's going on right now because they
remember me I owe everybody an
explanation but most importantly I owe
two important people an apology to talk
to you James Watts bro there's a lot of
smoke but then he talks about his mom I
guess he felt the anecdote that she gave
about his mom I'm talking I'm
inappropriately about her he felt was
really [ __ ] but he didn't want to say
that because he's trying to apologize
and I think his mom was really angry
that she that she used that against him
and he was he starts talking about his
mom and crying and she with the long
situation that just happened
I've had to learn at the hard way but
coincidentally enough Tati really was
one of the people to set me down and
tell me how it looked from the outside
in regards to my own mother
there you go well I know you want to
defend me and fight for me and go off on
comments when I ask that you don't
excuse me everybody
apologies I love how he's telling his
mom not to go off in a video it's like
you know you could talk to her and I
just want to say mom don't go off on
everybody please and this is my job to
do is anybody is saying or commenting
we're talking about here we go
waterworks you're an amazing mother I
just don't know why he's taught me to
talk about his mom it's like you guys
all you guys talk
yep presumably her his mom's gonna make
an expose video spilling the tea on my
own son his his uh metaphorical mom's
barium and I was root biological mom's
about to put the tombstone on his grave
yeah there you have it I'm so over
talking about change Charles how long
you been going well now since I said
that actually I have James Charles memes
you wanna look at these these are for
yes pretty fantastic biggest drama is
about these two the biggest YouTube
drama of the year and both our Senator
run guys look like this what's the deal
with this spider that I always see James
Charles compared to does anyone know
back there yeah yeah
that's it's from some game or creepy-ass
kids whatever it is oh man yeah it's
good [ __ ] is that picture of the right
of James real yes he did like a
meet-and-greet or he was taking photos
with makeup I mean I Who am I doesn't
talk but okay see that was edited cuz
that one isn't his white I guess this is
the real yeah oh but it's still bad yeah
yeah yeah that one not as funny I guess
no laughter there oh yeah this one I saw
this on Twitter a lot people were
enjoying this you know you're gonna like
this watching toxie's bidi a 40 minute
video that clip is so phenomenal like I
would say that what came without
jeopardy or price is right wheel affords
wheel fortune I would say that will
fortune was created specifically
everything culminated in this clip like
there's nothing better than that
oh this was great people were burning
his products I guess here's one genius
burning it in the trash man and bed
like a bad it is a taper oh no got my
whole pot to our podcast claim now I was
like genius that's like a pretty severe
fire in your bedroom and there's like
paper next to her and [ __ ] yeah and its
makeup products right there's probably
all kinds of oh yeah also you already
bought it for good yeah I can use it or
give it to someone dumb dumb people were
apparently returning his products and
mass here someone who works at the
counter of on these beauty places was
like getting tons of people coming and
returning imagine actually being that
upset that you I don't know just talk
about like I won't go out of my way to
go to the store I don't do that already
and I'm not upset about anything James
Charles falling faster than his sub
count fantastic brilliant fantastic
well that about sums that up I feel
exhausted from talking about how do we
do do we explain it I think you're
pretty thorough yeah I should try those
vitamins you should make some kind of
statement like this was a drama-filled
week that we will never see again
oh yeah cuz I guys the drama the sub
loss the the twists and turns this was
such a drama filled week that we will
never see the likes of which again
meanwhile like philip defranco just like
came out that he and keemstar having a
sexual affair would that be the best
youtube drama of all time
keemstar in philly dr gay and in a
relationship yeah just close the website
at that point dude that would be fire
and there's a video of it who do you
think i want bigger dick philly d or
keemstar
ah fair enough
yeah let's not go there if I had the
guest what do you do guys have an
opinion which one of them has a bigger
dick yeah no I think Philly deep I was
gonna say Philly D cuz I like him more
different yeah sure yeah I go he's
packing it Keane probably has like a
little like Kings probably pretty pretty
small oh yeah he's got a little gnomish
it's like I just up it's like a mushroom
it's like got a huge tip but it's really
stout it's got like a little mushroom
stub and he's probably got a wart on the
tip that looks like a gnome sitting on a
mushroom it's got like a huge wart on
his gnomish costs all right let's move
on team content for a week yeah thing is
no it's true I've heard through the
grapevine that he has a huge wart the
ward is like the same size of his
mushroom tip it's crazy okay we've got
abortion that's it that seems like an
awful follow up yeah I don't want to
talk about that we've got let's talk
about the freaking Burger King
depression meals you guys got to see
this man watch this ad just bear with me
cuz it's like a couple it's one minute
long and bear with me here and tell me
when this ends if you are not shocked
and awed by what actually this ad is for
so I'm just gonna play for you and let's
talk about it when it's done not
everybody wakes up happy
sometimes you feel sad scared crappy
crappy Elias is that she let me feel my
way can't wait to leave this
close-minded town
my boss is such a Freeman Creek
[Music]
my giga claim i'm commenting on it
[Music]
yes
I can't believe my student loan I'm
never moving out of my parents home just
got ghosted should've known pretty sure
nothin long the lyrics are pretty crazy
right now my girl yeah take your
opinions and suck it world should you go
girl sister he spilled it feel that
[ __ ]
[Music]
each through your phone in our River
brows
[Music]
no one is happy all the time and that's
okay
that's why burger meat burger meme
Burger King is introducing real meals
are you [ __ ] kidding me Burger King
you believe this corporate nightmare
these corporations need to stop this KFC
this Burger King there's Wendy's they
all need to go [ __ ] off you're not one
of us and then they're like supporting
Mental Health America but what exactly
are you doing nothing they're making
money yeah she's still just selling the
same burger yeah so we actually went out
and bought all of these for for Rizzo so
we've got here well we can bring them in
so yeah they've got the let's see you
guys gonna love this the blue meal the
yacht's meal pist meal salty meal don't
give a [ __ ] meal these are real meals
for real people
now that the I love to then do I get a
crown down yeah thank you which one do I
get yes yes I love the Burger King of
all people is making the depressed meal
because honestly nothing makes me more
depressed than eating a Burger King
burger
it's disgusting garbage it's crap is
disgusting and I love that they have
depression burgers because I don't need
help getting the press when I eat Burger
King either word they just starting [ __ ]
with McDonald's because they have the
Happy Meal yes exactly they're trying to
call up McDonald's for the Happy Meal
now they're being you know how dumb this
is they call it a Happy Meal cuz it
makes you happy when you get the meal
and you're not gonna have to be happy to
get the meal you idiots and you know
what McDonald's does because it's way
better yes this one is depressing that's
what Happy Meal makes you happy when you
get it okay if I get a meal and I'm
salty afterwards that's not a good meal
and I'm loo afterwards okay that means
you're [ __ ] depressed the depression
meal who thought this was a good idea
but also inside it's just a regular oh
yeah you're like oh is that this is some
interesting [ __ ] no it's just a whopper
and fries man
it's literally they're fresh suck by the
way their friends at work and their
burger what did we write Burger King cuz
I want to lower it I think we gave it up
it was a dear enough yeah Ian tell me
about the process of getting these I'm
curious the burger looks alright to be
almost you want one no you already had
one
well don't you know aunt taught me yeah
I went and got them this morning
and the woman at the drive-through had
no idea what I was talking about what
did you ask for I said could I get the
real meal that's what they call it the
real aunt the sad burger and she said
you want a grilled burger and I said no
the real meal she went it would take
about 10 minutes to grill a burger and I
said no I need the real meal and she
said I have no idea what you're talking
late what's in the grilled burger I have
no idea she just can't understand it'll
take 10 minutes to grill a burger
that shit's always grilled isn't it
about 5 to 10 minutes what as opposed to
how else are these prepare you and I
mean yet I don't understand 2 is from
what we looked up this promotion is only
being run at like 5:00 Burger King
locations nationally and now just
happened to be a so their marketing team
is so incompetent that the employees of
the five restaurants they don't even
know what the hell is happened well who
the hell would actually go there and ask
for a real meal I mean that's kind of
psycho but you went there yesterday in
and you said they were sold out right
yeah he told me to come back tomorrow I
have I find that hard to believe how do
you sell out of it just run out of
packages yeah what does that mean they
sold out I wonder also I like that they
got these crowns
eeeh I can clearly tell they D G
af you don't give a flop head gaff yes
Queen
you got a twist yours Ethan we can't see
the oh [ __ ] tell me by the way another
way well I'm going all the way I go all
the way around but going keep it going
keep it going I was like hurting my ears
stand yes I'm so small
yeah this this has got to stop I got the
whole variety pack smut I want you to
appreciate how far we went for this okay
these are all real meals we're the only
ones today to buy them or the realest
month research right that's right mmm
three our old french fry so you ate a
burger and fries today yep for breakfast
here before the show how do you feel I
actually feel good I could totally eat
another one of those burgers like I
can't even smell it I put in my mouth I
forget you another one he was like don't
you [ __ ] she threatened me and I was
like huh she's right I shouldn't eat
that I'm already depressed enough I
don't need a profession burger making a
[ __ ] worse but these corporations have
to stop I am NOT down I don't find it
cute on funny charming their food sucks
ask Burger King [ __ ] you time to spill
the tea the time to spill the diet coke
on you Burger King has no not this
apparently real by the way Burger King
tweeted this out him it's only a month
waifu like no not november you saw
burgers why are we talking about Nona
November why are they all trying to be
like relevant on social media I just
stop I don't think anyone ever bought a
[ __ ] Burger King meal because it's
some [ __ ] talk about no not November
on Twitter what is this [ __ ] good for
them no I can't this is so embarrassing
honestly the Wendy's ones are the worst
goofing around this afternoon which
one of these classics do you want to see
us deep-fry votes are in the frosty one
but we went ahead and deep-fried all of
them cuz it's a deep-fried mean Oh
do you understand that that you are the
worst
you're the worst I will never eat at
Burger King I will not eat your food
that's Wendy Wendy whatever they're all
ass yeah Wendy's stupid makes me angry
not as angry as this Burger King wall
dude they just hire like a fifteen year
old to run their social me yes you mean
yes I mean yes
Domino's is so wacky I don't get this
this one's pretty bad demons take off
your blindfold me no demons we got
Domino's promo code me a what why are
demons is this real I think it was from
bird box when all those memes were going
home no man who's this asian girl that
got to do this dumbass probably an
intern it's not even a real it looks
like they photoshopped looks Photoshop
the frickin blindfold on her bro that's
so bad
Wendy's talking [ __ ] about Burger King
well talk about calling the kettle black
you know Burger King also a spicy
chicken nuggets yeah but there's also
water in the bottom of the dumpster out
back if you're thirsty godom who is this
person who took the screenshot cuz they
liked the tweet yeah people liked it
they think it's cool that and relatable
and edgy that a big corporation would
were under Wendy's is so savage that
they would run their social media like a
15 year old sick yes you know it's
probably like a thirty year old guy
pretending to be lady's 12 yeah I'm
telling you Wendy's this sad
social media is run by a 30 year old
dude who jerks off to hentai okay yes
the UPS store is even getting into the
fray somehow if your child addresses a
letter to the North Pole you can leave
it with us we do shredding that's right
Savage is [ __ ] up
dear Santa please care my mom she has
cancer and she's dying UPS garbage you
understand what it means because you're
not American I'm not sure kids write
letters to Santa asking for Christmas
miracles and wishes and so that they
address it to the North Pole UPS Store
saying they'll shred it
Tom dear Santa my mom passed away and
I'm all by myself my dad is dying of
cancer what do I do sit-ups start
shredding Adam that's it I I'm kind of
over it today it's been hour and a half
I've got so much more guys but I'm gonna
save it I'm gonna save it are you
excited for the last episode of Game of
Thrones I think it's gonna be the
all-time worst episode ever made he's
been getting Game of Thrones this is a
whole can of worms you know you really
go there we can talk about this let's
talk about Game of Thrones all right
well I as you may or may not know I'm a
huge Game of Thrones fan I've read all
the books and I've been on board with
the stories this last season I mean
everybody's been complaining about for
good cause because I mean the plot has
just been so rushed it's just been so
ridiculously rushed over
you know HBO originally wanted ten
seasons but the creator's did to David's
were I guess over it and wanted to go
work on Star Wars they have this new
opportunity and so they just wanted to
lock it up real fast and the end of the
book was just so rushed
in the end of the story like stature
yeah
HBO wanted more HBO didn't end it is
these two the two creators mm-hmm and
I'm pretty sure that they've had now I
don't think they've parted ways with
george RR martin amicably I think George
is pissed about how they did the show do
you hate the part of Dan where they
explain the episode I like it I hate it
well I'd usually like it why do you hate
it you because I I don't need you to now
tell me why you think your writing was
so great right it's always like oh we
knew defense wanted this but obviously
you can't give them what they want
they're like John is supposed to be the
hero we all knew that so we wanted to
subvert expectations and have him just
meandering around the castle you only
got a dragon that's literally they said
that about dawn it's like and then
they're george RR martin contrast that
he pitched talking about the TV show he
goes yeah you want to subvert people's
expectations but when you have a whole
novel set up in a certain way and all
the clues and all the story is leading
one way if you just go ahead and change
it at the end then then the story
becomes a mess there's so many dead ends
in that show that they caused like the
whole thing about Dorne
the Dornish prince that the mountain
killed and all this total dead end
didn't go anywhere bran has ended up
like a tote like such as weird stupid
you know I mean everything's a dead end
honestly every time they're like for
three years now we knew that Arya was
gonna be this but we wanted to do it
this way I don't know it's like yeah you
guys wrote it I don't need to hear why
you guys are what George told them the
how would the story ended and so Bay
they basically just fast forward they
skipped ahead just what this this season
was yeah but there's some really dumb
ones
in fact you're talking about how they
won't get any kind of care this this was
such a great clip by clan gaffney so
this is perfectly what you're talking
about here's these guys talking about
their genius writing it just takes me
out of the show I don't need you
explaining to me
I just watched you know what I like is
on YouTube they have house [ __ ] was made
select the most recent episode which was
cinematically that was graphically
phenomenal it was beautiful it was an
achievement and in filmmaking and on
YouTube there's a 30-minute like mini
documentary about how they did all of it
like the special effects and the
coordinating everything and that was
fascinating yes did they show in that I
haven't actually seen that but I was
reading then they built like 17 yeah me
block said yes yes they've got nothing
Davis they show all of that it's super
they built it all and then underneath it
they also have chart ruins Wow so they
built first what it was gonna look like
when it's ruined
and then they continued it to be full
that's sick I mean yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you should watch it it's it's great
I loved every minute of it it's such a
bummer because I mean pretty much every
component of the show is is top top tier
yeah other than the writing it's just
like the act all the right visual
effects all of it really is unparalleled
for TV show anyway thing is once they
kind of strayed away from the source
material it just got more and more like
that if you look back at the pacing of
the first season it was so true to the
book and it was so fantastic it was as
incredible pacing and narrative
development and character development
and then like progressively as a show
went on that all just completely turned
into drama kept being so unexpected and
things like the red wedding or right or
what happened to Ned yeah which was like
you I mean they did they built that up
perfectly you I still can't get over
that moment yeah yeah it's like a Darth
Vader moment it's just so powerful and
so I think I think they really botched
the biggest moments in the books which
is kind of what happened in the last
episode that they kind of like what
should have taken place over the entire
course of like a whole season should
have like shown what happened but really
they gave it like one episode mm-hmm you
know well at any rate what you're
talking about how them like
just masturbating about their own
writing so listen to this you're gonna
love this well Danny kind of forgot
about the iron fleet and Euron's forces
they certainly haven't forgotten about
her the golden company has arrived in
King's Landing courtesy of the Greyjoy
fleet the balance has grown
distressingly either what are they any
kind of forgot about they aren't fleet
and Hurons forces
that fire but it's fine and sink it
grace
he's why he destroyed a good portion of
our fleet well Danny kind of forgot
about they aren't leaving
Euron's forces
castas Doon the Iron Islands and the
reach well Danny kind of forgot about
the power they explained it just kind of
makes me feel brain dead it's like I
just watched it yeah I can
how dumb do you think I I think about it
for myself for a minute I don't need
someone now chewing my thoughts for me
hmm
I don't know why it upsets me yeah I'm
actually with you I never watch them I'm
fine I find it really breaking yeah I
like the the inside look those are on
YouTube separately they aren't fleed and
neurons forces your own ships could be
anywhere or in more than one place you'd
be flying around the open seas alone for
who knows how long
this is the dumbest [ __ ] ever lengths
they go to King's Landing and then
somehow these dragons in the air don't
see them the iron fleet and just get 360
no-scope
it's just painfully bad I would have to
robe on Viserion and regal anyone she
forgot it they even the writer himself
said she forgot about the iron please
like
[Music]
never saw it go ahead yeah it's a shame
it's such a shame that the writing was
such a bad and we kind of forgot about
yeah exactly you know the latest episode
I was so conflicted because on one hand
I was so depressed about the culmination
of all these characters that I loved in
a follow him so invested in and watching
them all perish and just that so that
alone made me sad and depressed really
that the show this show I've been
watching since when we lived but in
Israel
yeah before we even made a YouTube
channel I think or around that 4:00 a.m.
we were watching it on like a box like a
really like SD old-school box yeah
and you couldn't wait so you would
actually watch it at 4 a.m. and then
watch it again with me yeah yeah that
was the first season I remember I was so
captivated by it here's a compilation of
the cast being disappointed with are you
happy with how things
[Music]
by the way brands okay we spent the
whole story building up brand as this
magical from the very first episode he's
pushed up the window and has these
visions and it's culminated in him doing
nothing all of those plot lines
everything supernatural in the show just
completely went nowhere
and just get ignored I was think about
this the other day in all of the seasons
since Jon Snow got resurrected like it's
barely ever addressed that this dude
came back from the dead like nobody
cares
also the Hound was brought back from the
dead like the Lord of Light it was like
he was so particular about who he
brought back from the dead but now let's
think he brought back the Hound the
hounded absolutely nothing you thinking
of no the helm was brought back to life
no the Hound was brought back to life I
don't think so yes he was that though
that crew happened upon him but that
dude who was brought back to life like
eight times his dude brought the Hound
back to life
that's why he joined there click on that
yes I'm pretty 99% on that but then that
and I got brought back and the other guy
and yeah and then that one douche that
was brought back to life like eight
times he his whole purpose was to save
Arya yeah yeah I guess so so that she
360 no-scope two dice yes I mean the ice
douche was like the biggest dud ever
yeah all the way yeah that one nowhere
Lord of Light went nowhere
bran went nowhere good stuff satisfying
conclusion yeah
they're all trashing the show man it's
crazy I really need to shut it your
brain
oh my god can let you go without asking
you a little question about game of
fashion this is over at the season
finale of Game of Thrones in one word
how I'm telling you this last episode
this Sunday is going to be the most
irredeemable pile of [ __ ]
that any of us have witness I have a I
have a premonition that a lot of people
been super angry about these last two
ups I think this one is gonna take the
cake there's no way they're gonna save
it because the making of it is so good
the last episode yeah if you haven't
watched the making over the last episode
you really should these two guys man
they're like they're just [ __ ]
everyone's [ __ ] up by being in such a
hurry to get out of there you know all
the work and all the love and HBO and
all the actors and George and everything
and the fans I do just want to bone out
the Optus HBO wanted ten seasons and I
don't think they could make it with
other people
contractually George gave them the
license to make it and nobody else yeah
that was like his big thing is that he
wouldn't work he only wanted to work
with people he approved gosh there's
this one scene in the long night where
they're like all the women and children
in the crypt well the dead people are
and everybody watching is like yeah and
he can raise the dead and Tyrion
Lannister in the past two seasons has
become the dumbest most useless
character like when they're using the
source material Tyrion Lannister
best most interesting and site full
character last two or three seasons
useless moronic always wrong doesn't
predict all these [ __ ] washes bring
the dead people back to life and they
put the women and children in a crimp
with all the dead people so Rob you're
in smart but it's not that smart
he is that smart he's meant to be that
smart but I hate to tell you that
unfortunately Barisan is God well you
got it about that sir bears no such a
great number of you I'm sure prideful
Nelson I've read the books and I have
reason to expect oh I've got a journey
here in fact if I'm honest I thought oh
I'm really looking forward to this
season I'm gonna have more to do I'm
gonna get my teeth into something I'm
really looking forward to did you have
words did you say anything - I did I did
ask and give an argument why Thor
Barisan should stay but at the end of
the day I mean you know John and David
you know they've worked out what they
wanted to do you know if you've planned
your book that the paper did it and then
you read an Internet someone has figured
out that the butler did it and you
suddenly change in midstream and it was
the chambermaid who did it then you
screw up the whole book we should get
these just foreshadowing early on and
you've got these little clues you
planted now they're dead ends and you
have to introduce other clues and you're
retconning it's a man hope to kind of
avoid the expected and Jon Snow has
always been the hero the one who's in
the Savior but it just didn't seem right
to us for this for this moment how do
you feel about the way that it ends
that's all there are no better writers
in television than Dan Weiss David
Benioff they ended it brilliantly better
than I could have imagined and you
people are in for it you people are in
brief oh damn what did you think you
have a strong opinion about it yeah I
mean yeah not a fan I mean III to have
read the books I've read twice actually
Wow yeah and like once early into the
show and then I reread them like about
two years ago and yeah I mean
I think what it really boils down to is
these guys they are I don't want to say
that they're bad writers just flatly
because obviously they gave you know
many seasons of a great show I just
don't think I think they're good at
adapting from a source material and as
soon as it diverged from the books you
know a lot of the changes they made
several seasons ago of like cutting big
story lines like Dorne is completely
different in the books and throws other
Targaryen so they cut yeah there's the
other Targaryen z-- and that's that was
like the whole plot that varies is a
part of so that kind of makes Mary's
character completely useless and you
know there's a lot of theories that that
whole plotline is going to be what
ultimately Cersei was in the show so
that's why Cersei just really stood
around not doing anything for the last
two seasons and yeah yeah I mean they
just lay is so dumb to at the end like
how much did Cersei go through how much
character development was there like she
blew up the SAP she got disgraced she
got her hair cut off in all this [ __ ]
and what did it amount to nothing it
went nowhere she just ended up standing
there in the frickin window so she
betrayed the armies for pretty much no
reason at all you know somebody pointed
out I saw that that the actress that
play Cersei is actually one of the
highest-paid on the show and this season
it's like quite a deal for her she paid
so much money for I don't know a grand
total of maybe like ten lines of
dialogue that's right just standing on a
balcony for a long time well I think she
got like a million Perret yeah something
like she was literally just gazing yeah
that's a good deal the gaze of miracles
that she was brought on it to uh
it's all kids it's disappointing man it
makes me sad that makes me sad the loss
of this show and characters that I love
makes me sad the last episode was so
heavy I mean like 80% of all the
characters died yeah and so much I mean
a lot of people take issue with the Dany
losing it and killing everybody but I
mean at least on paper I actually like
that that's where the story went but it
was so unsubstantiated so right
microwaved they just microwaved it yeah
like you said I mean these guys you know
not to excuse
them but yeah they've got this deal to
make a trilogy of Star Wars movies so
you can understand from their
perspective I mean that I mean how many
things are a step up from Game of
Thrones not many but that's that's one
that you know that is an extremely
prestigious [ __ ] up part of history
now yeah well they should have just
passed it off to somebody else again
it's rapid over no George wouldn't give
consent for that hmm I guess I guess but
they're gonna go make some shitty Star
Wars trilogies and everyone's gonna
remember as the guys that [ __ ] Game of
Thrones and went and made some shitty
Star Wars trilogy but they're probably
gonna make a ton of money so what did
they care especially when you look back
I don't know if you've looked at their
IMDB
but prior to nothing right not just
nothing like some really cringey [ __ ]
like some of the worst stuff ever do you
remember the x-men origins Wolverine
movie like the worst x-men movie though
I mean that was their beauty on yeah the
one where Ryan Reynolds is Deadpool but
like isn't you know George was involved
in the first couple of seasons too as a
consultant so oh you even wrote scripts
yeah so I mean George was a TV writer in
the 70s and 80s so he had actual writing
Trump's I'm really hoping that George is
gonna finish the novels and then we're
gonna get a remake of the ending a
remake of the whole show and its really
true to the story kind of like how do
you redo it though full metal alchemist
didn't make it animated I will dude
animate it would be so good I'll be
super cool
either warm I mean they're not gonna do
anytime soon but maybe 10 20 years from
now when then I would love a tit to see
these last season's remade but they're
making a prequel but again there's no
source material to draw them so I think
it's gonna be shitty it'll be different
writers though to be fair yeah but they
have no source material to draw for the
spin-offs almost never work though that
shit's going nowhere well I am excited
to watch the last episode I guarantee
everyone's gonna hate it
I almost certainly guarantee it got
predictions I don't want to say yeah
all right I don't want to say I'll tell
you all fair okay cuz I read to kind of
a spoiler but I don't know if it was
true or not
oh that's right I did hear that there
are some leagues but I I read like a dot
some [ __ ] it was on a trending
Twitter post hmm and they lit her on a
trending Twitter post they trended this
they said this is what happens here's
the leak that predicted it and all of
their major plot points were right hmm
up until now so what they predicted for
the end I hope it's not true
but what they predicted for the last
episode is truly the worst possible
scenarios I mean just so dumb well I
guess we'll find out in a couple days
yeah I told you not to tell me no yeah
yeah well I'm depression crown on I'm
feeling blue but it's Friday TGIF God's
day a holy day baby so let's go out
there and let's say some God blesses
some poeple blesses some whatever
blesses thank you guys for watching it's
been a for some time it's been a podcast
you know how we do ela is getting really
pregnant so it could happen any day now
by the way yeah I think we'll make an
update this weekend due date is June 6
it's three weeks from now something that
three weeks yeah three weeks love answer
but at this point it's like it could
happen anytime yeah oh boy so we're
gonna make an update video I think this
weekend cuz we just gotta tell people
like hey we might disappear for a minute
cuz it's baby time
I think I'm just gonna come in and do it
solo and just update people just keep it
short and sweet and then keep you know
yeah then go home do an hour
should I watch the baby coming out or no
do you want to I don't know
it's a miracle life dude I guess
whatever you want I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna forbid you would you would I watch
it yeah I like my initial reaction is no
but then I don't know maybe I think that
moment where they actually plop out cuz
it sounds like the head is crowning
crown a crown and crown a crowning and
then there's a moment where like
everything plops out yeah but that's
crazy too because you've got like the
baby but then also like the placenta and
everything all this blood and
discharging [ __ ] comes rushing out I
don't know man I don't know if I can
live with that my head exactly maybe
just done the miracle of life yeah baby
just don't dance saying no you can just
yes guys thank you for watching we love
we appreciate you thinking for this jarn
James Charles drama-filled beautiful
rock riot this is we'll never see the
likes of which again hipster Franco
meanwhile they're sucking each other's
dicks 69 filming can't wait to find that
and update you guys so have a great
weekend a fantastic weekend we love
y'all we'll see you next time at the a
Street podcast my two cents edition
thank you everybody Tata Tata from
tattoo
[Music]